[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the school your daughter goes to they
did have father-daughter dances yeah
they do every year and you have to go as
a costume theme i remember one year and
it's super creepy because you're like
wait it's couples then oh i already know
my costume what maybe dane cook and his
girlfriend
[Laughter]
[Music]
if you had to put your finger on one of
our asses
tom don't even ask the question i mean
oh yeah i guess is your husband so hey
big boy was filming cleveland cleveland
seven shows seven shows at the what
where was it
the agora
you filmed seven shows i filmed four i
will film seven the next time really
it is so much easier four shows was
perfect i mean we did the first show was
not that great first show was not that
great and we're like great get it on the
second show if not we get another night
of filming do the next show there's a
[ __ ] mustard stain on
[Laughter]
your wardrobe needs are minimal babe
ruth i just walked off stage you know i
talked what you guys think of that
well and all you do is wear pants you
don't even have a shirt i would have a
mustard stain it was right up here you
should have used that [ __ ] tape
i know
the shirtless guy i can't watch porn
that even is remotely young no
because because george is 14 so all her
friends are like they're young ladies
yeah and i can't i'm like [ __ ] that like
i have to watch old lady
like broken isn't that interesting and
it'll probably the age will keep going
up that you can respond to as your
daughter's age you know what i mean oh
i'm sure normal although my father
doesn't seem to know that
yeah you definitely don't think i just
married a 34 year old your dad [ __ ]
chicks younger than you
oh my god
it's a viral challenge that we put out
on facebook much less like the ice
bucket challenge right right and it's
yeah right it's a tight shot and it's
like hey guys my name is brooke christo
it's ready for the it's ready i'm ready
for the uh the butt plug challenge right
now you got to try to guess am i putting
a butt plug in or am i not putting a
bump again and it's just a shot of my
eyes and it's me going
and
people have to guess if you really did
it or if you didn't do it and then do
you show them and then you pull back and
you either have pants on or you're naked
so you're you're struggling to pay rent
is the scenario like you're like [ __ ]
yeah and then
would you do
some type of sex act on camera and then
for what amount of money so like
i would i said you know i like i would
put on like a luchador mask and
masturbate to get like some rent money
um christina was like yeah maybe foot
stuff and then she was like or a gang
bang and i was like well hear me out
here and then she goes but i'd wear a
mask i'd wear my because i didn't know
mask was an option i would do like an
entire basketball team gang bang
interracial i want to make money [ __ ]
the mess doesn't mean it's not you it's
still you
you can't just go
and there's 11 guys
okay hold on i'm going to show you i'm
going to show you what you just did okay
what would my scenario be oh i'd suck 20
dudes dicks but i'd have a mask on yeah
no one will know he's still doing it but
i didn't say sucking dicks
what do you think about that different
they just ramble
i'm interested in getting gang-banged
but you're pretending that once the mask
goes on it's not connected to you it's
still you
i want someone to break a light bulb in
my [ __ ] but i'm wearing a mask
oh bert answer the question whoa whoa
whoa we're not just leaving this what i
feel like i'm fine i don't i don't think
it's that big of a deal what do you mean
it's not a big deal
but
it's a big deal it's a gang bang with a
[ __ ] basketball team basketball team
and i'm paying rent for like three years
bro no what do you think you think tom's
a bit of a sociopath
i you know i've never seen that
there's yes
really cool answer i remember i remember
and i can't share this story i can't
share the story because it i it's it's a
it is a secret
but tom told me a story one time
it was a about a
long a past relationship he had with
someone and he told me a story
and what excited him in the story was so
disturbing to me yeah that i went
yeah and to this day it's like it's like
leanne doesn't do ass play you can't
[ __ ] around with an [ __ ] and so
i'll never be able to change her mind
about that yeah and so but i remember
tom telling me that and i just to this
day i think about that i think about
this i knew what the [ __ ] you were i
honestly don't know what you're talking
about i wish i i wish i could share but
i would hate to bring it up and then you
go i really didn't want uh it was like
two guys talking
oh okay okay one of those long road
trips about butt sex i don't know no i
don't know it wasn't about butt stuff
i really don't know what it is
i don't know i don't want to share it oh
my god i mean him not wanting to share
it oh it's not it's not even that bad
but i just don't want to share it yeah
but it's just no i
it's about sex it's about sex okay okay
is it about
farting
no it's like it's like okay imagine if
someone was like um
imagine if
i can't even say it like imagine
someone's like don't you love fajitas
and then you go oh i do love fajitas
it's like in your favorite part when you
just put your tongue on the on the metal
and it burns your tongue you're like no
i don't do that
and then and then your buddy's like that
is my favorite part and you're like
and i was in the car going i've never
done that and now i'm thinking how come
i've never done that and how come i'm
not into that i've seen it but i've
never done it so that's got you okay
that's the story all right well we won't
expose anybody
i think you are so exhausting the jokes
that casey anthony jokes um please don't
so unnerving what so
okay i gotta go i'm gonna get some
coffee
[Laughter]
big anal guy or no never done it yeah
not with her
once in in camp this guy did it to me
so
where's do they know where casey anthony
is yeah she's fine she's not guilty
she's fine oh okay she's just chilling
in florida somewhere i'm sure casey
anthony's the person that i found out
you could get chloroform online oh yeah
you could just buy chloroform online i
didn't know that's not real yeah
you didn't get chloroform and just it
just sent to your house
amazon yeah on amazon you can get
chloroform i'm not even [ __ ] around i
have a joke about that i don't even know
it's real yeah oh yeah crazy it was so
funny um yeah i definitely okay real
quick glad you shared that with
everybody
every lunatic
are you [ __ ] kidding me this just
made makes my weekend so much easier and
then like when they're in trial they'll
be like this guy burke chrysler was on a
podcast
he said it this [ __ ] doing that then
nadav said he would do uh submissive be
like spit on and spanx but no scars
any is like yeah i'll just shoot a scene
right now today no mask no nothing and
then come back to work here tomorrow
like he's he doesn't he doesn't care
he'll shoot a scene he said he'll shoot
a scene no problem
josh thinks it'll help him sell tickets
and he is well he is willing to do a
scene with a girl he picks the girl and
then 10 guys can come in at the end and
come on his shoulder
like
i'll tell you what
i i would definitely like to see that
guy in person
i don't know if i care about his comedy
that much but i would like to see that
human being yeah that chose that
scenario i know and we're shooting that
one we're gonna can i be one of the guys
that comes on his shoulder i want to
wear a mask
then you didn't do it
oh no it's not me
i love it because i want to get gang
banged by an interracial basketball team
but i'm going to be wearing a mask so
all right tomorrow yeah say leanne's
like how you doing you're like what's
the [ __ ] questions and you divorce
her right
okay
that is deleted
so
how are you doing what's with the
[ __ ] what are you writing a book i'm
out of here yeah so you're free okay
you're free and clear
and then you go to do a gig in tampa
and you meet this girl at a bar she's
brunette she's super cute yeah got a
little attitude which i know you like
yup and she's um she's like you're like
hi and she like pantomime like puts her
hands around your neck she's like ah and
you're like
[ __ ] her ass
shots
you're bathing or something i'll like
her you're like that's two shots and i'm
like okay yeah yeah that is kind of your
dream girl we'll talk about that yeah so
she's she's giving you [ __ ] she's kind
of checking you a little bit and you're
like i just got divorced yesterday and
feeling pretty good i'm not into
questions yeah and she's like snapchat
that's happening she's [ __ ] around
with you and then
you guys leave together you're like i
haven't been with another woman in so
long like you've added a whole backstory
about this joke it used to be very
simple
and then you go back to your hotel with
her
start making out you're like oh this is
so
new to me i know i'm just so used to one
person and then she's like oh really
check this out and she drops your pants
and she just goes
and just fully down your throat spits on
your balls put your legs back in like to
change my die die and start by the way
by the way this is a lot like the secret
i wasn't gonna tell
keep
going so she's just like like every time
you're like wow she just got back to
choking on oh wow
that's nice she's like talking loogies
on you
you're like oh my god my wife didn't do
this she's doing you know the reverse
[ __ ] uh and this and double handed
yeah oh my god and you're just right as
your eyes roll back you're about to
finish and she goes and you're like here
it goes and as you come she goes i
killed my [ __ ] daughter
and is what's the question
no what's the joke where's the punch
lines
wait what part's the funniest to do that
don't you think it would ruin your
orgasm oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah i have
that from from not even joking around uh
um leanne started ruining my orgasms
with that stuff no she i was having an
orgasm one time and she was like
[Music]
the television show that she the shield
you were
i was a [ __ ] that was my role it said
the [ __ ] what was the booking like uh i
i actually didn't even have to read for
it they just booked me how great is that
yeah tommy just looked at me and they go
he looks like a [ __ ] can you tell he's
been excited to have you bert oh he goes
he goes we're gonna have so much fun
with you when you're here and i was like
in my head i'm in the shower i'm like
there's going to be a scale
if tom died you and the boys would move
somewhere nice i think you'd leave l.a
you'd move somewhere nice santa barbara
yeah and then you write about that and
you probably would not get on stage
again i don't know
i think she would hook up with like
gardner
like the gardener yeah the gardener
maybe the team of gardeners like the
whole squad
like uh
you still write the checks and you're
like yeah i'll still write the checks
and they're like me and uh jose
i
and all the gardeners would run a train
on me is that what you're saying you
took to that you jumped over there you
suggested it you used the language they
would run a train on
[Laughter]
babe you don't think something like that
would happen no
one of the dads was given a speech about
uh
like be about the dad's club
and uh yeah like there's a dad's club
and he's like you know when i was there
and it was it was so bordering on being
inappropriate
because he was like you know i'm here
for the dad's club and i just want to
let you guys know that you know i mean
this used to be our dream like in all
girls when you were kids but and
everyone's like oh
it's like but you know you don't have to
feel creepy when you're coming around
and like hanging around as a you know
what i mean everyone's like just stop
talking and i'm in the back going go
harder go harder talk about the showers
i did this uh a gig in madison once yeah
where it was at the club but they're
like it's just gonna be
girls and their dads like a sorority
group bought out the club
and i did this speech i was like no one
is ever gonna i was doing like i said no
one's ever gonna love you the way your
fathers love you and all the dads were
like
nodding and i was like it's a love that
you'll never understand so you you'll
probably wonder how you could ever
reciprocate
the love that your dads give you because
it's unlike anything else
and i go
and the oh really the only thing that
would even come close would be if you
were to take
your roommate's panties and put them in
a bag and give them to your dad
and i just stayed on it i was like your
dad jerks off and he wants to jerk off
again he's not jerking off to your mom
get your [ __ ] roommates panties maybe
socks whatever they have that smells oh
and send it to your dad and i just
stayed on it and there's like dads
laughing like really loud yeah and then
just absolute headshakes
but the staff was like that's the best
moment we've had this year like all i
have to say is it's fatter than bert and
people really love it people always come
up to me and they go hey man you're not
as fat as
they say and i was like yeah i know
and then like i don't get it and i go
i'm also not racist okay by the way my
bus driver leans into the racist thing
he loves that joke so much he does yeah
but he doesn't do it as a joke he does
it
what makes him laugh is he does it for
real he just says
people will recognize him and he'll just
go you know he's a [ __ ] racist and
walk away
and i go ron they don't know that you're
joking he goes yeah that's what makes me
laugh that's what makes it laugh he goes
yeah he does does it all the time all
that he did at a meet and greet one time
and it got uncomfortable because they
didn't know he's my bus driver he's just
standing there and he's like i can't
believe you guys are waiting in line to
shake hands with the [ __ ] racist and
they're just sitting there like wait are
is he really racist and i was like guys
this is a joke and they're like it
doesn't sound like one this is awesome
yeah it's great it's really great this
has by the way i did an interview today
and the guy goes so
so
in your specials you're always like your
body's always the joke i go i'm the
skinniest i've been in 15 years in this
last special and he goes are you serious
i go yeah it's 220 and he goes wow i
thought you gained weight i go
i feel like it perfectly represents you
like you you are
in the special who you are for real you
know and that's a cool thing to see like
i was like this is a hundred percent
because you know sometimes you could
tape something shoot something and
you're like
[ __ ] like that's not really who i am you
know like or that didn't come out right
yeah but this came out to be this is you
dude thank you this might be the best i
mean i got there's only i've never read
reviews or anything and you want your
friends to like it yeah and so thank you
no i'm gonna i'm gonna hit you hard here
in a little bit yeah it was great
it was it's really fun i love the title
i think it's such a great it says it's
exactly what you do it's a secret also a
[ __ ] throwback it's funny to call it
a throwback it's a throwback to when
comedy specials were funny yeah
right it's like somebody out there
without there's no pretentious vibe he's
just like bummers no it's just funny
it's funny stories and funny jokes
i feel like thank you because i feel
like i feel like uh
i sometimes i feel bummed out that i
don't have like an angle that i'm
preaching about you know these days
everyone's got something to preach about
yeah and i just it was for me it's just
funny stories don't get me wrong i
didn't like it i'm talking about it i'm
saying other people might like it yeah
okay so wait you booked this role you
said so so i booked this role
um
and chiklis is i think chiklis and this
other guy are directing this episode
but chiklis is on set
so i i i read the breakdown and i and
the scene and it's me watching my wife
[ __ ] a black dude right and the black
guy and my wife are both in this house i
see them in the house and so i just got
into role and i started playing with my
dick like legit playing with my dick
right
and uh they pull up and she gets
outraged this lady yeah this lady the
real person
she calls cut she goes this is
ridiculous he's touching himself
and in my head i'm like i read this
wrong i was like i thought that said to
play with yourself and i'm like oh my
god i'm so [ __ ] embarrassed i've
never acted in anything before this is
the first thing i ever acted in this is
when we were shooting hurt burt by the
way so
she was i'm not gonna work with him and
so she moves they split us up
and uh michael chiklis and this other
guy forget the other guy's name come up
to me and i go hey man i'm really sorry
i think i misread this
i i can do it again i don't have to
touch myself and he was like no great
choice
i want
oh here we go i like this scenario
all right let's start off when i get two
million dollars from life insurance yeah
hey she's worth a lot that's good two
million yeah
anyways so yeah okay she's dead tom and
i like talk about this all the time
who's the second probably a boat i buy a
boat first
what was the second question what's the
second wife like yeah what kind of
second spouse are you with i'm saying
tom's gonna go for like the dalmatian
she thinks i'm gonna get a trophy
a real dum-dum like 25 years old yoga
instructor never pushes back never
challenges him total dope
just like she's like
oh yeah yeah right like a total dumb
yeah one
yeah and she goes to all your shows and
watches every single one of them great
job baby she's so good even when i get
like heckled she's like that was great
dude yeah you're uh he's so funny he
couldn't he doesn't turn it off i love
him this is what i mean i am laughing
all day long yeah that that girl i'd
probably go with i'd probably go
with someone like that i would i
definitely would like to do some stuff
that i haven't been able to do like i'm
not talking about you live a single
person's life yeah no no no no i meant
sexually i liked like
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you